comme chaque dimanche on vous retrouve
patrick cohen pour c'est arrivé demain
bonjour jean marc jancovici ingénieur
consultant climat énergie président du
cercle de réflexion the shift project
avant de voir vos propositions ce
constat la terre respire mieux depuis le
début de la crise les confinements et
l'arrêt des activités économiques ont
fait chuter les émissions de co2 de plus
de 5% au premier trimestre d'après les
premières estimations
en réalité c'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
chaque année pour être dans la
trajectoire de l'accord de paris est
contre nous dans cette histoire parce
que le principal gaz à effet de serre
que nous émettons qui est le dioxyde de
carbone à la très mauvaise idée d'être
éternel une fois qu'il est dans
l'atmosphère tant qu'il ne revient pas
en contact avec le sol
la seule manière de retirer du co2 de
l'atmosphère c'est qu'il soit repris par
les plantes par la photosynthèse ou que
si ils se dissolvent dans l'océan et ça
fait que le co2 ne décroît que très très
lentement une fois qu'il est dans l'air
et donc tout le co2 qu'on a mis dans
l'air maintenant il faut vraiment
arrêter leurs maîtres et donc décroître
très vite nos émissions et pour
respecter les 2 degré d'élévation
maximale de température entre ce qu'on
appelle l'ère préindustrielle d'ailleurs
1850 avant qu'on commence à s'amuser
avec les machines à vapeur et 2100 eh
bien il faut que les émissions se
mettent à baisser de 5% par an tous les
ans par rapport à l'année précédente
pour les 30 ans qui viennent on va dire
c'est à dire qu'en gros il nous faudrait
un colis de supplémentaires tous les ans
pour donner un vendeur pour qu'on
respecte les deux degrés on ne se rend
pas compte à quel point c'est un effort
titanesque
il se trouve que l'accident que nous
sommes en train de vivre en ce moment on
donne une meilleure idée de l'effort qui
nous attend est peu et j'espère que ça
va un peu réveillé les les esprits et
qu'on va pas penser que ça va arriver
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts alors
justement votre idée c'est pas de tout
arrêter un mois par an vous venez de
publier avec le chief project un
document de 50 pages avec un plan de
transformation
de nos activités essentielles un plan
concret et détaillé c'est pas de
l'idéologie ou l'incantation il ya qu'à
faut qu'on le temps est venu et c'est
l'idée c'est de trouver pour chaque
secteur des solutions pour le rendre
plus sobre moins dépendante des énergies
carbone c'est exactement les émissions
de co2 deviennent de l'utilisation de ce
qu'on appelle les combustibles fossiles
alors très précisément pétrole gaz et
charbon
on les appelle combustibles fossiles
parce que c'est des faux cils cdrs de
vie ancienne sédimenter par là et il
faut qu'on arrive à faire 5 % de moins
de ces combustibles en clair tous les
ans alors le gros problème c'est que
c'est ça qui a fait la révolution
industrielle pouvoir d'achat
l'urbanisation l'industrialisation les
transports facile l'agriculture pas cher
et c'est donc ça va pas de faire d'un
claquement de doigts non plus ce que
nous avons déjà publié c'est le nôtre
temps de travail en fait on a dit dans
quel cadre on allait réfléchir et ce à
quoi on allait réfléchir et le gros
problème pour être tout de suite
désagréable c'est que comme ces
combustibles ont permis de mettre plein
de machines au travail et d'augmenter
très fortement la production donc notre
pouvoir d'achat faire avec de moins en
moins de combustibles fossiles pour dire
un gros mot tout de suite c'est
malheureusement travailler dans un
contexte dans lequel l'économie n'est
plus en expansion mais en contraction
c'est bien ça le sait bien faire le gros
problème est par ailleurs tous les gens
qui en ce moment ont peur ou ont déjà
perdu de perdre leur entourent parce que
ce qui est en train de nous arriver va
se payer des quelques millions de
chômeurs se disent légitimement qu'un
truc essentiel dans la vie c'est quand
même d'avoir un job donc le cadre dans
lequel on va travailler c'est comment on
fait pour avoir un boulot dans un
contexte dans lequel des émissions dont
globalement l'économie se contracte et
tout en assurant à chacun une forme de
confiance en l'avenir voilà c'est ça
c'est ça le l'espèce de quadrature du
cercle à laquelle on va s'attaquer et
pour être pragmatique on va s'y attaquer
secteur par secteur
donc comment on fait pour se déplacer
comment on fait pour se loger comment on
fait pour se nourrir comment on fait
pour s'habiller etc et on va faire ça en
deux temps le
les temps c'est dans quelques semaines
on va faire des suggestions de
contreparties qu'il faudrait demander
immédiatement au secteur qu'on est en
train d'aider pour pas qu'il recommence
comme avant
manifestement dans ce monde là par
exemple n'y aura pas autant d'avions qui
vole alors au moment où on donne un
chèque à air france est ce qu on lui
dira partait comme avant où est ce qu'on
lui dit non fait autre chose tout de
suite maintenant il ya des lignes que
vous allez tout de suite fermé où on va
tout de suite diminuer le nombre de
créneaux au décollage à orly et roissy
et vous allez-vous réorganiser en
fonction pareil pour la construction
automobile pareil pour le bâtiment
pareil pour le tourisme etc
donc ça c'est dans quelques semaines et
après entre l'été et la rentrée on
soumettra quelque chose de beaucoup plus
détaillée on va un peu faire concurrence
à monsieur le maire donc une certaine ou
plus exactement on espère être écouté
par lui pour donner des grandes lignes
et des choses assez concrète à on va
parler emploi
on va parler objets on va parler choses
à faire on ne va pas parler avant tout
de suite parce que l'argent en ce moment
sauf créé d'après difficile par contre
ce qui est beaucoup plus difficile c'est
de savoir dans quoi les gens vont
travailler et pour faire quoi et oui bah
pour prendre cet exemple que vous venez
de citer
des milliers de salariés des millions de
familles qui ont beaucoup à perdre parce
qu'elles vivent de l'automobile et de
l'aéronautique
vous avez des idées pour on pourrait ici
il faut il faut bien distinguer deux
choses quand on parle de l'économie en
fait il faut distinguer les entreprises
il faut disent les gens qui travaillent
qui va être important de notre point de
vue c'est des gens qui y travaillent
je vais tout de suite très désagréable
si les actionnaires perdent leur argent
on s'en fiche complètement actionnaires
c'est pas une garantie de capital ça ne
l'a jamais été et moi il faut que je
suis actionnaire jeu à côté d'être
président by side project je suis
associé d'une société de conseil dont je
suis capitaliste et si jamais je perds
mon capital
ça fait partie de la vie ça fait parti
des riches que j'écris on n'a jamais
signé un contrat garantissant que cet
argent là était inaliénable donc
l'entreprise elle même sera pas
nécessairement au coeur de notre
réflexion par contre les gens qui y
travaillent oui alors que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des gens qui travaillent dans
l'automobile d'abord il faut savoir
qu'une partie des gens qui y travaillent
aujourd'hui sont en france donc ça dit
on va faire un distinguo nécessairement
ceux qui travaillent en france et ceux
qui travaillent plus
ensuite il va y avoir des choses qu'on
peut faire après telle est des choses
qu'on peut faire à plus long terme donc
il faut regarder par exemple les flux
d'entrées sorties regarder avec comment
est-ce qu'on peut jouer
vous pouvez très bien pendant un temps
en bouche et moins de gens que vous n'en
faites sortir à cause des départs à la
retraite et à ce moment vous avez
naturellement un secteur que vous pouvez
faire baisser en effectif pendant que
ailleurs et c'est toute la difficulté en
général vous augmentez les gens qui
travaillent pour prendre un exemple il
ya un chantier dont on parle
régulièrement depuis des années dans ce
pays qui est la rénovation du bâtiment
vous savez qu'il va falloir modifier
fortement beaucoup de bâtiments pour les
rendre plus économes en énergie sa
demande de faire rentrer des gens rapide
calcul montre qu'il faudrait quelques
centaines de milliers de personnes en
plus dans l'artisanat du bâtiment est en
fait la vraie question c'est pas tant
comment est ce que vous faites un peu
diminué chaque année les gens qui
travaillent pour l'automobile ça fait
pas de très très compliqué la vraie
question c'est comment on fait rentrer
des gens comment vous former des
compétences comment vous leur donnez
envie d'y aller comment etc ça va aussi
être refaire la question qu'on va se
poser beaucoup de questions encore à
vous poser jean marc jancovici vous
restez avec nous on va poursuivre dans
un instant après une pause de 9 heures à
10 heures pour c'est arrivé demain sur
europe 1 avec jean marc jancovici qui
dirige le shift project cercle de
réflexion consacrée à la transition
énergétique qui formulent des
propositions on viens de l'entendre
vous êtes une voix qui compte jean marc
jancovici dans le dans le débat sur le
climat l'énergie experts très reconnue
mais avec deux singularités vous prenez
à la fois le nucléaire source d'énergie
la plus décarbonés que vous jugé
indispensable pour la la réduction des
gaz à effet de serre et aussi vous venez
d'en parler la décroissance pour
atteindre le même objectif
est-ce que c'est tenable aujourd'hui
dans nos économies appauvri est en
récession et qui n'attendent justement
que le que le retour de la croissance et
de la prospérité
c'est bien pour ça qu'on pense qu'on
fait oeuvre utile et on n'a pas envie
d'être des prophètes de malheur et de
dire aux gens vous allez en baver
pas du tout on a plutôt envie de dire
aux gens vous savez ce qui a fait la
croissance jusqu'à maintenant c'est la
disponibilité croissante des
combustibles fossiles du pétrole du gaz
et du charbon
et il se trouve en europe cette
disponibilité et déjà contrainte à la
baisse en fait elle y est contrainte
depuis 2000
quand on regarde très très bien ce qui
s'est passé dans le monde occidental est
très précisément et en bétail en fait ce
qu'on a appelé la crise des subprimes en
2008 c'était déjà une crise énergétique
ça a été précédée par une stagnation de
la production mondiale de pétrole le
début du déclin du pétrole conventionnel
tout ce qui n'est pas le schéma et de le
pétrole de schiste et les sables
bitumineux et il ya un lien direct est
assez facile à établir entre ce qui
s'est passé dans le monde économique et
ce qui s'est passé avant dans le monde
énergétique et là nous sommes en train
de revivre une accélération de la fin
une évolution de même nature
il se trouve que la production totale de
pétrole dans le monde même en rajoutant
ces pétroles dit non conventionnel
s'était arrêté de croix depuis quelques
années était probablement passé par un
maximum fin 2018 et vous voyez que
depuis fin 2010 8 le commerce mondial
avait commencé à stagner voire décroître
la production industrielle dans l' ocde
avait commencé à décroître etc et ce
mouvement va s'accélérer dans les années
à venir malheureusement très mauvaise
nouvelle pour aux auditeurs nous ne
retrouverons pas la croissance dans les
années à venir et probablement que le
niveau de production que nous avons
connue en 2007 sera pour l'europe un
maximum historique qu'on va avoir du mal
à auquel on va avoir du mal à revenir
donc c'est bien dans ce cadre là qu'il
faut réfléchir à partir du moment où
vous savez de façon absolument certaine
que votre fiche de paie il n'a pas
augmenté vma même légèrement s'éroder à
l'avenir la raison commande de voir
comment on arrive à s'organiser dans ce
genre de monde et que ce genre de monde
où il ya deux choses dans ce que vous
dites jean marc jancovici d'abord c'est
que la sortie de l'énergie carbone va se
faire de gré ou de force de force parce
que la ressource pétrole diminue et
qu'elle va s'éteindre progressivement
dans les prochaines décennies
malheureusement déjà de force et la
deuxième chose c'est vous expliquer que
notre source de croissance
c'est le pétrole c'est l'énergie carbone
oui vous êtes sûr de ça oui parce que
téva qui a permis de nous construire un
costume d'iron man pour de vrai grâce
aux machines qui fonctionnent avec du
pétrole du gaz et du charbon et même en
france l'essentiel des machines
fonctionnent au pétrole
nos voitures fonctionnent au pétrole nos
camions fonctionne au pétrole au pétrole
et au gaz allez on va dire aux
combustibles fossiles nos chaudières
fonctionnent au fioul et au gaz bien
avant de fonctionner à l'électricité
une bonne partie des machines
industrielles en particulier toutes
celles qui permettent de fabriquer de
l'acier et du plastique du ciment etc
fabrice fonctionne pardon au charbon au
gaz et au pétrole donc les combustibles
fossiles c'est ça qui ont permis de
mettre en route un énorme costume d'iron
man qui a multiplié la puissance de nos
muscles par 1000 1 millions des millions
parfois un laminoir industriel il est
puissant comme des millions de fois les
muscles de l'ouvrier qui le commande
donc ces machines qui nous ont donné une
puissance surhumaine et qui permettent
de faire la production c'est pas vous ni
moi qui avais fait l'acier qui vous qui
permet de faire les boutons devons
porter sur vous et la voiture que vous
avez peut-être utilisé ce matin donc
c'est la chine qui produisent tout ça et
avec moins d'énergie vous avez moins de
l'or une expression j'utilise souvent
c'est des croquettes pour machines à
l'énergie dont vous avez moins de
nourriture pour machines et donc moins
de machines au travail et densément de
production malheureusement mécanique et
il va falloir qu'on fasse avec alors je
reviens à ma question de départ est-ce
que la décroissance n'est pas synonyme
forcément d'appauvrissement généralisée
au sens où on l'entend classiquement
avec le pib évidemment crient maintenant
la question c'est encore une fois
sachant que de toute façon on va pas y
échapper
eh bien comment on s'organise vous savez
dans les modèles économiques qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui la croissance n'est
jamais une conclusion du modèle avec des
hypothèses qui tienne la route c'est une
donnée d'entrée alors ça va peut-être
vous étonner ce que je vous dis mais la
croissance l ai postulé dans les modèles
les modèles ne prévoit pas là il prévoit
allez on va dire une modulation de cette
croissance en fonction de la manière
dont on s'organise mais elle est
toujours postuler au départ c'est ça qui
est très étonnant où les gens se rendent
pas compte mais c'est comme ça que ça
marche donc et si les modèles étaient
prédictif on aurait vu venir la crise
pendant ce moment donc le
la croissance malheureusement c'est un
souhait parce qu'on a des désirs de
croissance il ya des neurobiologistes
qui explique très bien ça notre cerveau
primitif qui date d'il ya des dizaines
de milliers d'années il est câblé pour
que l'on n'en voyais toujours plus parce
que l'on sait pas comment sera la
prochaine fois on aura à manger où la
prochaine fois où on aura l'occasion
d'avoir ceci ou cela mais du coup on a
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à s'y li té
mais c'est un délire la planète elle est
ce qu'elle est et malheureusement 8
milliards d'individus il ya des moments
où nos désirs il bute sur l'horizon de
l'orion physique du possible si on sait
s'organiser encore une fois ce qui est
essentiel c'est d'avoir confiance en
l'avenir et moi je considère que un
monde qui va se contracter alors qu'on
nous raconte des sornettes sur le fait
de la croissance va revenir et un monde
beaucoup plus dangereux car monde qui
s'est fait organiser pour que en concert
de l'espoir dans ce genre de contexte
je reviens votre plan jean marc
jancovici je le disais ébauche de plan
mais détaillé chapitre par chapitre
mobilité énergie logement santé
industrie culture agriculture
est-ce qu'on peut tout faire en même
temps où je vous vois ce que vous
estimez que l'on pourrait définir un
ordre de priorité ce qu'on va devoir
définir c'est un ordre de priorité dans
les moyens et vous parliez tout à
l'heure du nucléaire en fait mon temps
pis mhz pour le nucléaire vient
exactement que cela vient d'un ordre de
priorité pour les moyens bien que je
considère qu'aujourd'hui vouloir
remplacer du nucléaire qui est là qui
fonctionne qui en france n'a tué
personne
alors qu'il fait courir des risques mais
le talent c'est courir beaucoup plus
chaque année ils restent en vente libre
donc je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
commencer par supprimer le nucléaire en
supprimer le tabac eh bien vous avez un
ordre de priorité sur les moyens dont
quatre seulement dont on peut pas tout
faire il paraît plus urgent de
reconvertir une partie de la circulation
automobile en autre chose de réorganiser
le paysage agricole de réorganiser nos
villes et de ce nous occuper des
logements que de remplacer des centrales
nucléaires qui présentent pas de danger
plus que ça quand on comparera aux
curieux par des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires voilà c'est ça le sait
au titre de cet ordre de priorité que je
considère que le nucléaire c'est très
très bien en tant son principe après ça
veut pas dire que l'on sait
nucléaire il est pas un débat peut
discuter si on veut de ce qu'il faut
construire des repères tout de suite
vous prolonger les centrales à ça c'est
un débat intéressant direct mais mais le
fait qu'ils faillent conservé voire
augmenté de l'énergie nucléaire pour
amortir globalement le risque de se
retrouver dans une situation
inconfortable est pour moi une la
conséquence de ce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire un ordre de priorité dans
les combats et quand on est amoureux
entre la montre il faut vraiment bien
choisir ses priorités parce qu'on n'a
pas de défaire un mot rapide non jean
marc jancovici sur la poursuite du
chantier que que vous avez lancé dont
vous avez lancé un financement ainsi
bâti fait un appel à consultation sur ce
document oui on a lancé un financement
participatif parce que le chiffre
project est une association
d'entreprises
c'est une des particularités de notre
association donc on est une association
environnementale
on se sont intéressés à la question
on est quand même financé par des
entreprises alors on dira rassure défis
lancés par les entreprises dans les
palais de votre parole un peu quand même
parce que les entreprises qui va te les
pieds chez nous ça va un peu pour mon
indépendance d'esprit et mais pourtant
sur ce chantier là on n'avait pas le
temps d'aller discuter avec des mécènes
entreprises en leur disant est ce que ça
vous intéresse financer ça donc on s'est
lancé dans une première mais qui restera
limité à ce chantier qui est qu'on a
fait appel au grand public en lançant un
chantier a effectivement un financement
participatif et on a eu l'énorme
surprise parce que moi je m'y attendais
pas du tout de voir que l'objectif qu'on
vise alors on se donnait trois mois pour
l'atteindre ont 15 jours là on l'a
quasiment éteint donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya une grosse appétence à mon avis pour
ce sujet là et c'est un motif d'espoir
que j'ai c'est que je constate que dans
la situation actuelle qui est quand même
une situation dure
il ya encore une fois des millions de
gens qui vont perdre leur job
il me semble que l'intérêt pour bâtir un
monde environnementalement meilleurs ne
faiblit pas au contraire un certain
nombre de gens place de l'espoir dans le
fait que ce gros coup sur la tête qu'on
va prendre va nous être utile pour
changer la manière dont on s'organise
pour l'avenir merci beaucoup jean marc
jancovici je rappelle
le titre de votre film tant que shift
project et on peut trouver sur votre
site
évidemment ce document et toutes les
informations nécessaires merci d'avoir
été ennuyé avec nous ce matin